ja das eine ist wie regiert wird das
andere ist wer überhaupt regiert wer
gehört zum scholz regierungsteam und was
sind das überhaupt für typen ja jetzt
gehe ich einmal rüber und brauchen nur
kurz eine kamera denn die wollen wir ja
noch mal zeit wollen wir noch mal zeigen
einzel neue regierungstruppe das ging
jetzt etwas schneller als geplant das
heißt das steht noch nicht auch wenn die
ampel schon steht gucken wir mal ob sie
bei uns auch schon steht hier also das
ist nochmal der koalitionsvertrag wir
wollen ihn aber doch die mannschaft
zeigen und klicke einmal durch hier sie
hier ist unsere neue
regierungsmannschaft und die fängt
natürlich mit dem bundeskanzler an das
ist doch völlig klar noch nicht gewählt
aber das war ja unstrittig also in der
ampel wird er die nummer eins ganz
interessant wer noch zu ihm gehört das
ist nämlich dieser mann hier den werden
sie noch richtig kennenlernen wolfgang
schmidt wirklich der alle ängste
vertraute von olaf scholz hat den
koalitionsvertrag ausbaldowert
geschrieben tatsächlich getextet an
seinem computer wolfgang schmidt er wird
kanzleramtsminister also bleibt ganz
ganz dicht dran an dem künftigen
bundeskanzler an olaf scholz und dann
ist das natürlich eine ganz wichtige
personalie hier christian lindner das
steht auch fest die fdp hat ihre
pöstchen ja mittlerweile verteilt also
christian lindner wird finanzminister so
viel ist klar und volker wissing sein
generalsekretär der wird das ressort von
andy scheuer von andreas scheuer
übernehmen er wird künftig
verkehrsminister im neuen kabinett auch
den werden sie noch kennenlernen das ist
marco buschmann der war bisher
parlamentarischer geschäftsführer bei
der fdp und er wird jetzt übernehmen
künftig das justizressort wird spannend
sein wenn es zum beispiel um die
impfpflicht geht die fdp hat das hier
ausgeschlossen das wird ein großer
software den nächsten tagen in den
nächsten wochen in der ampelkoalition da
unter anderem wird er im mittelpunkt
hier stehen dann im künftigen justiz
ressort und auch diesen namen können sie
sich schon mal drauf schaffen das ist
nämlich bettina stark watzinger gestern
schon bei bild live hat sie einmal ihre
ziele erklärt als künftige
bildungsministerin also nachfolgerin von
anja karliczek und sie hat zumindest
schon mal ausgeschlossen für die
nächsten wochen dass die schulen
bundesweit geschlossen werden das also
antritt satz bettina stark watzinger die
beiden sind erst mal leer ausgegangen
waren auch in der verlosung alexander
graf lambsdorff für das außenamt für das
außenministerium im gespräch und marie
agnes strack zimmermann für das
verteidigungsressort im gespräch die
beiden landen nicht auf den kabinetts
stühlen und das sind natürlich ganz
wichtige personen im künftigen kabinett
von olaf scholz annalena baerbock sie
wird außenministerin auch das steht fest
und robert habeck er kriegt ein
superministerium hier steht wirtschaft
das wird aber eben auch den bereich
klima umfassen also das ist hier die
achse der macht bundeskanzler olaf
scholz finanzminister christian lindner
und künftiger wirtschaftsminister
robert habeck mit dem sidekick hier im
auswärtigen amt annalena baerbock und
dann gibt es fragezeichen noch in der
neuen regierung arbeit und soziales geht
wahrscheinlich wieder an ihn an hubertus
heil das ist aber noch nicht offiziell
verkündet das innenministerium geht
wahrscheinlich an sie an christine
lambrecht die im moment noch im
justizministerium sitzt und das ressort
familie außerdem vorübergehend von
franziska giffey nach deren ausscheiden
übernommen hat das sind relativ sichere
posten und hinter den anderen
ministerien aktuell tatsächlich noch
fragezeichen das ist die aufgabe vor
allen dingen von spd und grünen in den
nächsten tagen diese pöstchen noch zu
klären die grünen werden das heute
machen die spd dann nach und nach in den
nächsten tagen da kommt es ja auch auf
parität an fifty fifty männer frauen und
man will nicht alle aus nordrhein
westfalen haben also das wird noch etwas
kompliziert für olaf scholz fragezeichen
doch im kabinett aber die kern posten
die sind ja verteilt annalena baerbock
außenministerin robert habeck super
wirtschaftsminister olaf scholz sowie so
der bundeskanzler und christian lindner
bundesfinanzminister